ten of us have been abducted by aliens
because they view us as being
representative of the human race and
what they're going to do is they're
going to test us to see if the human
race is worthy of joining the
intergalactic council of planets and if
we're not they're going to kill us all
and and turn earth into a a mushroom
farm because that's their oil
so they take us together in their
spaceship and they say you 10 represent
all of humanity and the re and the fate
of humanity rests in your hands we will
give you a test and the test is tomorrow
we're going to put 24 hours from right
now we're going to put you all in a
completely dark room and line you all up
one behind the other so if this is one
guy let me see if i can draw
so this is a guy in the front he's
i don't know
he is looking a little worried
someone described me as the bob ross of
mathematics so
i'll attempt to do a little bob ross
work right here so this would be the
first of us
he has a business tie on and
whatever he's facing this in this
direction and then there's 10 more of
them so instead of redrawing that let me
just copy and paste it
we all look mysteriously similar to each
other
that's the second one
and the third one there's ten of us like
this i'll do one more
uh
like that you could kind of say oh
that's good enough there's 10 of us and
we're essentially lined front lined up
front to back so that you know this guy
all he sees is the back of this guy's
head and he can also see the back of
this guy's head maybe there's a slight
incline so that they're you know maybe
the the floor is like this let me see if
i can draw at the floor the floor is at
a slight tilt so one guy is standing
right here another guy standing right
here another guy standing right here
there's 10 of us in a line we're all
facing in that direction all this guy
can see is all this guy right here can
see is the wall this guy can see the two
guys in front of him this guy can see
the one guy in front of him and there's
ten of them that goes all the way back
to 10.
so what they tell us is we're going to
line you up like this they even draw a
nice diagram like this because they they
want us to give us a they want to give
us a fair chance of preventing earth
from turning into a mushroom farm and
they say while the room is completely
pitch dark we're going to place a hat on
each of your heads and the hat will
either be
i don't know
move
mauve move
so this would be a move hat
or they'll be
magento they'll be
green
so either get a move or a green hat
on your
on the back of your head and the hat
will be designed in such a way it won't
have a big rim so that you can't look up
and see your head it is you know this is
alien technology so it's completely
impossible to see the hat on your own
head
and the distribution of the hats will be
random it could be all green hats it
could be all well i'll say purple
because
i'm not quite sure how to pronounce
mauve
so it could be all purple hats it could
be half purple half green it could be
nine green and one purple they don't
know it could be any combination of hats
and what they're going to do and they
tell us all of this is that they're
going to start with the person in the
back
so they're going to start with let me
so if these are the you know this is the
front wall this is the floor this is the
first guy right here second guy third
guy fourth guy fifth guy six guy seven
eight nine so this is the tenth guy
they're all faced in that direction
they're going to start with this guy
right here
this guy right here and say what color
is the hat on your head
and if and he'll answer either move or
purple i mean he'll either say purple or
green
and i guess mo well no he can only say
purple or green i have to be i have to
be exact here he could he'll
he can only be say purple or green and
he has to say it well he could say it as
loud as he wants but he has to say it at
a an even tone so that not not more
information can be conveyed other than
the fact that he thinks his hat is
purple or green although this guy is
close enough that he can hear it
everyone's going to hear what everyone's
going to say but there's no intonation
you could say and if you're right if you
say my hat is purple and you are wearing
a purple hat you will live and the 600
million people that you represent will
also live and where they live will not
be turned into a mushroom farm
now if you're wrong
then they will immediately if you know
uh
what is that star trek weapon displace
you and they'll also turn all the people
where all the land they'll do it to all
of the people you represent and turn all
of their land into mushroom farms so
there's a huge incentive to try to get
this right
so say we're gonna do this tomorrow and
your goal obviously is to try to save as
many lives as you can
and so we're going to put you in a room
and you guys can discuss this for the
next 24 hours to come up with a system
so that when we put you in the dark room
and we put the hats on each of your
heads
we'll put i shouldn't be drawing brown
hats it's either going to be we put the
hats on your head and then turn on the
lights oh i have to forgot to tell you
that they're going to put us in the dark
room you can't see anything we're all
lined up then they're gonna turn on the
lights and so then this then they're
gonna ask what color is the hat on your
head he obviously can't look at his own
head but he'll see everyone else's hats
and likewise this guy
he can't see his own hat and he can't
see the guy behind him but he'll hear
what this guy says and he can see all of
the hats in front of him
so they'll turn on the lights and then
after this guy if he's right he lives if
he's wrong he'll be displaced and then
they'll go to the guy
the next guy and then ask him if he's
right he lives and all the people he
represent live if he's wrong he also
will get displaced and they'll keep
going all the way up to the first guy
so our goal to essentially save
civilization or at least human
civilization
is to come up with a system to save as
many of us as possible
to and and so that's the first take of
the brain teaser so if you want to kind
of pause it
right here and actually before you pause
it let me just clarify you know you
can't all you can say is either purple
or green no intonations you can't say
purple or purple to kind of convey any
type of information all you can say is
purple or green or pronounce it in some
weird way and um and there's no you know
weird trick where you can kind of look
with the side of your eyes or anything
like this this is you have to do it
completely based on
what you hear and what you say and if
the aliens catch any
hint of you guys trying to kind of cheat
or all of us i'm one of us
to cheat this they'll just evaporate
everything and turn everything into into
mushroom farms so that's the problem
statement how do you save as many people
as possible
and if you want to pause now feel free
to do so and now i'll give you kind of a
small hint because this doesn't help you
it's easy to think of a lot of solutions
that might save a couple of people
but there's actually a solution that
will guarantee
saving nine people so that's the
solution that you cut you have to come
with up with and feel free to i'm for
the rest of this video i'm essentially
just going to keep giving hints and then
eventually give you the solution so
the goal is actually really to save nine
people
and you can imagine which nine people
it's going to be and for once again
pause it if you don't want any more hits
it's going to be these nine people
these nine people are guaranteed to be
safe
saved and this guy obviously is just
going to be guessing he's the first guy
to be asked what color his hat is he has
no information he can see the people in
front of but he has absolutely no
information as to what color this hat is
so he just guesses so there's a 50
chance that he's right assuming you know
without any other information we assume
that there's a 50 50 chance that your
the hat on the top of your head is a uh
a a purple or a green one so you know
your expected number of people you're
gonna save is nine and a half
with with the system and so these people
you have to come with it where these
people are guaranteed
guaranteed to be saved and so you know
there's a couple of things that are more
probabilistic that don't quite get you
there that might come to mind
immediately and once again stop this
video because it's fun to kind of think
of these yourself but you know this guy
might
this guy might just look at the number
of um
this guy might just see okay how many
green hats are there and how many purple
hats are there and then whichever there
are more of he might say oh my hat is
let's say there's six purple and uh
three green in front of him he might say
my hat is purple and just you know he's
either right or wrong and he might get
displaced but at least he'll convey that
information to the rest of the group
that hey the majority of the hats are
purple so you're better off guessing
purple than green and it'll save at
least six of these people because
they'll all guess purple and that's okay
and in this situation you're guaranteed
to save more than half of these nine
people so you're guaranteed to save at
least five of these nine people and then
probabilistically maybe you can get up
to seven or or eight
um then there's the other method is for
every um
well there's there's a ton of i don't
want to go into because i realize i'm
out of time so here is the real
the real deal solution so really pause
it and wait and watch it tomorrow unless
you don't want the solution the guy in
front or the guy in the back what he
does
so there are
a bunch of people one two
three four five six seven eight
nine ten people and they're all wearing
hats what he does and remember we have
24 hours to come up with the system so
everyone is in the system and and we
don't know who's going to be in what
order also that's the other thing but
that actually doesn't help or hurt you
much anyway
so the guy in the back what he does is
he counts
he counts the number of
of
green or purple hats
right so he counts the num this is the
system we come up with and this is true
of whoever is in the back whoever is in
the back has to do this right
so if he counts that the number of
if he if he counts at the number of
green let's say this is our system
he said he counts the green actually
only so count the green
and he determines that the number of
green is an
odd number
if he determines that the number of
green that he sees in front of him
is an odd number that he is going to say
green
for the guess on his the top of his head
if the number of green is an even
number is an even number
he's going to say
purple
and of course he doesn't know what his
hat color is but at least
well one he has a 50 50 chance of saving
himself but now what happens
now
by giving this information to the rest
of the group
by screaming green or purple if he
screams green
if this guy screams green right my hat
is green
then this guy who's the next guy in line
the next guy to be quizzed
knows that the person behind him saw an
odd number of green hats
this guy saw an odd number of green hats
now this is interesting
if he
counts the number of green in front of
him
and he also sees an odd number of green
hats
then that means that he was not one of
the green hats that this guy saw
so he must be a purple hat
right
so he'll just say i have a purple hat
and he will live
right and then you'll go to this guy
you'll go to this let's go the other
situation let's say that you know this
guy he screamed green which means that
he saw an odd number of green hats in
front of him if this guy counts the
green hats in front of him and of the
eight people in front of him and he says
wow there's only an even number of green
hats he could say wow i must have a
green hat and so then he'll say green
and then he'll be right
likewise this guy
this guy we'll say the situation where
this the first situation that i said
this guy has a purple hat on right so
this guy saw an odd number of green hats
he screamed green
and so this guy he also sees an odd
number of green hats because he's not
one of the green hats so he says purple
he lives
this guy
this guy all of a sudden
and because this guy said purple and he
lived i mean you didn't hear any uh
buzzer and actually you know he's going
to live because the system will work
right he knows that the uh that there
must be an odd number of green hats from
him
down forward right because this guy
didn't say green
so if he knows that there's an odd
number of green hats from him down
forward
and if he sees an even number of green
hats
right he knows that he must be one of
the green hats so he'll say green
and in that situation this guy if this
guy screamed green
then that means that
if this guy saw an odd number of green
hats from here on down
and one of these guys behind him or
every time someone behind you says green
after that then the number of green hats
that are
um
that are odd or even in front of that
person will change and so they kind of
keep having to keep track of that in
their minds to figure out if the hats in
front of them are going to be green or
purple actually let me give an example
because that's probably the easiest way
so there's
one
two
actually let me just do it with a
neutral color so i don't waste time so
let's say the hats are
green purple purple
green
purple
green green how many is that one two
three four five six seven eight
nine
ten
so we said if you so this guy you go to
the first guy right here and you say and
so he counts he says okay how many
greens are there there's one
two three four
five there are five greens
so the greens are odd
the greens are odd which says that he is
going to say green that's the system we
come up with so when they go up to this
guy he says green and he's wrong so he
actually gets
eliminated
and maybe the aliens are willing to give
us a pass on the first guy but let's say
he gets eliminated but he said green so
now all of so then this guy on down
knows that in front of that guy there
was an odd number of green hats now this
guy he looks he looks forward he counts
one two
three
four five green hats so he also sees an
odd number of green hats so he knows
that he must not have a green hat
because if he had a green hat then it
would turn the number of green hats that
he saw into an even so he doesn't have a
green hat he says i have a purple hat
and he lives
he lives
now this guy
he counts the number of green hats in
front of him one two three
four green hats he says gee i only see
an even number of green hats
up until this guy he saw an odd number
of green hats i must be a green hat so
he says green
check
now this guy's turn so first of all
he knows how many green hats this guy
saw he knows that this guy saw exactly
four
green hats because if this guy had seen
five green hats he would have said
purple so this guy knows that this guy
saw four green hats but he saw he sees
only one two three green hats
right so he knows that he must be one of
the green hat so every so he he screams
green so check
so then this guy knows wow there must be
only three green hats from him on down
because this guy must have seen three
green hats if he saw four he would have
said purple so that guy uses that same
logic
to say okay there must be three green
hats from me on down i see three green
hats so i must not have one of them i
must be purple and you just keep on
going down all the way until everyone
answers correctly and you save at least
nine people and the bulk of humanity and
if you give a pass on on the first guy
you save all of humanity anyway i hope
you found that one enjoyable this is one
of my favorite uh brain teasers and i i
apologize because i realized when i was
trying to explain it without the example
maybe have gotten might have gotten a
little confusing but hopefully this
could this example
explain things a little bit better
although it might seem be confusing to
see green and purple written in blue see
in the next video